[Music]
Syracuse New York Melinda's calling I'm
Melinda how are you hi Dave I'm gonna
talk to you I just had a question I am
I'm worried that I'm the tightwad but
it's frozen I'm listening to you okay my
husband and I are having a hard time I
think I want to go really really really
fast and I feel like he's just a weight
pulling me mm-hmm
and I'm like willing to get two or three
jobs and he's starting to get upset he's
like don't do that you need to be home
with the family and you could advise me
okay so he's willing to go on the
journey it's the speed of the journey
yes and it's killing me without
obviously not literally
I understand person so how much debt
have you all got 29 it's all student
loans now 29,000 Sallie Mae and what's
your household income eighty but I just
changed jobs where I don't work over the
summer so but I'm guessing it should be
about the same time what do you do for a
living I'm a mental health counselor
okay and so can you do that some
freelance of that over the summer so
I've looked into it I talked to another
co-worker and they are but there's right
now on the military family life
counselor and I wouldn't be able to do
it in this area because they don't want
people to see me as that role and then
doing another job if that make sense
sure sure okay I had the job come next
school year
so I was gonna get like a truck driving
CDL and that schooling is would take up
the entire summer and I was thinking I
could work on weekends counselor Oh a
truck driver yeah that doesn't sound
like that goes together to me what am I
missing but it pays well
oh that's all it is okay all right
again what's the hell what's your
household income again overall your
overall household income again eighty
eighty thousand I'm still in the Army
Reserves okay are you guys I am 35 he's
36
okay all right and so you you just
started this get out of debt journey and
the two of you are sitting down doing a
budget together right we took your
Financial Peace University class three
years ago mm-hmm and then when I had the
job change I'm like we're not doing a
budget we don't know where this money is
going what do you be using we should
have like 2,000 extra and so you took
the class and you didn't implement it at
the time not the budget no other stuff
is amazing like my eye my rosted 22 last
year okay so you're putting money in a
Roth no I'm not I'm not putting anything
in oh it's just what it did okay it's
just what it did by itself okay all
right well I think what you probably do
is go all right I get honey that this is
you talking to your husband I get that
you don't want me going all the time
working six jobs okay but I'm really on
fire for us getting rid of this debt and
moving our family forward so we are
misled a little bit I can slow down some
of my intensity to meet you but you've
got to meet me where we actually start
doing the budget and we actually sit
down once a month at once a week and go
over where the money's going and that we
are going to work these baby steps and
the only if we're doing that and the
only question is how fast we work them
then I will give you I will give on that
point but I can't not do this stuff
after going through this class it's
changed the way I look at it and I want
this debt paid off and I think you know
that's a fair thing for you to ask him
to do and I don't think it's a hard
thing I think he'll do that don't you
he will and we are I
he still wants to go on vacation we
don't have any no no you're not working
the baby steps if you're going on
vacation when you have $29,000 to do a
budget but he still wants to okay you're
fun things we're doing a budget but
we're not sacrificing to get out of that
that's a problem that's different than
you're working all the time okay okay so
you know basically you guys have where
you're not an agreement is not about you
working all the time or you're not in
agreement is is he's not really wanting
to follow the plan that you learned in
Financial Peace University right he
still wants to go out and not be like me
and and go buy a bunch of crap you can't
afford and continue to be and so he
wants to do you know financial piece
vacations and doing going camping her
yeah and so he somehow he missed the
part about living like no one else so
later you can live like no one else and
so that's where you guys we've got to
spend some time dreaming again and go
you know we can't we can't spend
everything and you know we're acting
like normal people again and if we spend
everything on fun then children do what
feels good
adults devise a plan and follow it and
that now that's a reasonable thing for
you to be fired up about you wanting to
work 60 sixteen jobs and go be a truck
driver when you're a mental health
counselor is a little weird
so I'm with him on that I'll take his
side on that but the and the problem is
if you do all that stuff and he's still
mr. fun all you're doing is buying fun
with all that work and that's not gonna
work so you guys need to get on the same
page as far as what your goals are and
what we're willing to do to hit those
goals and then you got to decide you
know are you gonna work the stuff you
learn in financial peace or not the
answer before was no you weren't and
then the question is are you willing to
read to you know you might want to go
back through the class wouldn't hurt you